The question
before the House's concurrence and third reading of Bill 2:08,
the two spirit and Transgender Day of Visibility Act,
Commemoration of Days, Weeks and Months Act
demanded all those in the chamber in favor please rise.
Honorable. Mr Canoe.
Honorable Mr Canoe. I. Honorable.
Mr Fontaine. Honorable Mr Fontaine.
Honorable. Mr Altamaray.
Honorable Mr Altamaray. Honorable.
Mr Weeb. Honorable Mr Weeb.
Honorable. Minister Azaguera.
Honorable Minister Azaguera.
Honorable. Minister Salah.
Honorable Minister Salah. Honorable.
Mr Caustician. Honorable Mr Caustician.
Honorable. Ms Smith.
Honorable Ms Smith. Mr Owosko.
Mr Owosco. Mr Pinook.
Mr Pinook. Mrs. Cook.
Mrs. Cook.
Mr Nesbit. Mr Nesbit.
Honorable. Mr Bushy.
Honorable Mr Bushy. Honorable.
Mr Simard. Honorable Mr Simard.
Honorable. Minister Marcelino.
Honorable Minister Marcelino.
Honorable. Minister Schmidt.
Honorable Minister Schmidt.
Honorable. Minister Cable.
Honorable Minister Cable. Honorable Minister Naylor.
Honorable Minister Naylor.
MLA Sandu. MLA Sandu.
MLA Legacy. MLA Legacy.
Mr Balkan. Mr Balkan.
MLA Malawi. MLA Malawi.
M L. A Chen.
M L A Chen. M L.
A. Moyes.
M L A Moyes. M L.
A Pancreats. M L a pancreats.
MLA Kennedy. MLA Kennedy.
MLA Devgan. MLA Devgan.
MLA Loezelle. MLA Loezelle.
Mr Oxenham. Mr Oxenham.
MLA Della Cruz. MLA Della Cruz.
Mr Brar. Mr Brar.
MLA Morose. MLA Morose.
Emily Bariza. Emily Bariza.
Mister Pershot. Mister Pershot.
Mister Jackson. Mister Jackson.
Emily Lamaru. Emily Lamaru.
Emma. Mister Evazliu.
Mister Evazliu. All those in the chamber opposed,
please rise.
Oh, my god,
that's disgusting. Order.
Order. Mr Schuler.
Mr Schuler. Mr Ginter.
Mr Ginter. Mr Narth?
Mr Narth,
we will now proceed to the virtual vote
will conduct the alphabetical roll call of members participating
virtually. As a reminder to all virtual members,
please respond clearly with either I vote yes or I vote no
only when your name is called.
I would also remind members to unmute their mics
only when they are recognized
and then immediately mute them again once they've declared their vote.
Uh, the page will now conduct the vote.
Emily Cross?
I vote yes. Thank you.
Emily Cross. Yes.
Mr Gertzin?
I vote no. Mr Gertzin?
No votes no. Sorry, Ms Laughlin.
Yeah, one moment.
I vote yes. Ms Laflin votes yes.
Emily Redhead?
I vote yes. MLA Redhead votes yes.
Haha,
let me do
it.
Gays 40, nays 4.
I declare the motion carried.